Justina is going to start off this hour
in Raleigh North Carolina
hi Justina how are you I'm good how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up okay
well I'm calling on because we're on
baby step one my husband and I and we
have a one-year-old son and before we
started this whole my makeover we
borrowed from my son's birthday and
Christmas presents that it got a flip
one part and then the other part is with
Christmas coming up he's going to get
more money and I don't know do we deal
with use gift money as part of a family
income through suicide for him
and if we pay him back do we put him on
our debt snowball how many money does
not yet
well we borrowed from birthday Christmas
and no Bellingen it was for $45
how much 445 okay so hit you cleaned out
his piggy bank
yeah fur fur his whole life his birthday
and Christmas and so how much will he
get at Christmas um I'm not sure how
much is on hundred or two thousand
probably closer a hundred okay what is
your household income um it's about
28,000 or 2,800 great now what is it
that angels 28.5 know you two adults
need to get on a budget and live on what
you have coming in you don't live off of
your one year olds birthday money that's
kind of ridiculous
so no if you want to pay that other back
at some point that's fine it's not that
big a deal but you know going forward
you need to just keep his little money
in his little piggy bank and you all
need to be on a budget and be living on
what you make the reason you got there
is you guys are so desperate because
you're out of control with your finances
right right yeah so we got to get in
control that's the moral of the story
because we don't want to lean on the
one-year-olds birthday money to keep the
household
right that's just kind of crazy so no we
need you need to get on a budget have
you guys got your every dollar budget
going yet uh we're don't use every
dollar but we have been doing that paper
paper budget okay
well that's good start are you doing
some things to get your income up yeah
we're hoping to us to income at like
parts we've been working part time and
that ended with the election and then
we're looking for more part-time and the
husband's looking for a better full-time
great great that's good news and how
much debt do you guys have twenty-nine
thousand on one we've got an AC loan
student loan and credit cards no car no
car art yes to pay for cars good good
okay well you're scratching and clawing
through and you've got to get on a
written game plan that both of you agree
to each month before the month begins
and you're doing the right things and
you do the right things or to get your
income up and your outgo down and then
make the dollars that you have behaved
but I'm not going to sweat the you know
the money that has already gone that's
not a big deal but I would just swear
off of you know whatever money he has
come in for his birthday just goes into
his little piggy bank or his little
savings account and that kind of stuff
and you you don't need to know that's
not part of the household income this is
gifts to your child and I would keep
that separate there's not a legal issue
but what it you know what is signals is
is that that the symptom of how how to
control you guys were and now you're
starting to get in control you shouldn't
be anywhere near that again so hey
thanks for the call hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show